hello everyone and welcome back to the
skilling open we are in the second match
of the semi-finals uh between magnus
cross and inani pognishi
magnus was able to win the first match
and now nepo started the second match
with a win it was the game we've shown
uh yesterday and now this is the second
game the two of them are playing magnus
has the white pieces and it's uh it's
quite a quite a lovely game so let's
just dive straight into it
so magnus with the white pieces uh goes
e4
uh sorry about that uh we have c5 by
nipple uh
going for the sicilian defense and now
magnus as uh
he he needs a win so he has to try and
make something up he needs a win
uh to either uh just win the win the
match out right if he
if he is able to draw the second match
he won the first one that's a victory he
goes to the finals
uh and uh well he he definitely doesn't
want to allow nipple to win the second
match and then to go
into blitz tie breaks because there just
anything can happen even though magnus
is a world blitz champion
uh you kind of want to settle things in
the in the longer time format
so here c3 not going for the standard
knight f3 d4
against the sicilian uh this is the
allopin variation we have knight to f6
uh charging the pawn right away and now
e5 we have knight d5
and now knight to f3 knight to c6 by
nepo
and bishop to c4 so this is very
standard stuff we have knight to b6
challenging the bishop
and bishop back to b3 and here uh c4 are
challenging the bishop right away is the
most popular option however nipple goes
for
d5 he offers magnus to capture it so he
does e captures and d6 alpha songs
played
queen captures and now magnus castles uh
we
bishop the e6 taking care of white's uh
incredibly strong light square bishop
and magnus trades it with cactus
captures and then now
a4 preparing to kick away the knight
with with a5
uh we have queen back to d7 uh now
preparing
uh to move the spawn and now a5 this is
not a problem for black knight to d5
and now even a6 so this is uh an idea to
weaken black's king side uh if uh
if black captures of course then you're
able to activate the rook then the
knight will become a little bit weak and
uh nip of course doesn't allow this he
plays b6
b5 also was an option he prefers b6 and
only now
d4 so magnus waited some time to play
this move but this is all still
uh considered theory so captures and
captures challenging the knight on c6
and here we have e6
uh strengthening the knight in the
center preparing to develop the dark
square bishop
and hopefully castle and here uh the
this position has been reached before
queen to a4 is a known move knight to b5
is a known move
but the move magnus plays in knight
captures and c6 is a new move in the
position so
as of move 15 uh we have a completely
new game
on our hands and nipple of course
recaptures and here queen to g4 now this
is the idea behind carlson's deviation
from the known lines uh
nipple will have some problems
developing the bishop as magnus will be
attacking the g7 pawn so nepo decides
all right we're probably not gonna
castle this game let's go h5 challenging
the queen and maybe we can bring the
rook into the game via rook to h6 at
some point so
queen back to e2 uh magnus just
just moves back and now b5
uh here uh we have knight the a3
bringing the knight into the game now
you can uh
challenge this b5 pawn so nepo
immediately grabs it bishop captures on
a3
rook captures an a3 and now f6
strengthening the center e5 can be
played at some point
uh we have rook to b3 again going after
that b5 pawn
and here knight to c7 defending it with
rook to b4
uh gaining now more space for the rook
you can go rook to
rook to e4 you can go rook to d4 uh you
can go rook to h4
so a lot of possibilities for this rook
on the fourth rank
uh but it involves giving up the a6 pawn
but it's not a problem since magnus will
win it back so
queen captures an a6 by nipple and now
comes queen
rook to h4 going after this pawn and
while you
could defend it with something like g6
this is just weakening your position
uh too much queen d3 is coming with with
an attack on this
pawn and there's just not much you can
do you can't go here because of queen
check
picks up the knight and uh any any other
moves
are just not enough it is just a
terrible position for black
so after rook h4 we have king to f7 nepo
gives back the pawn and
rook captures on h5 now we have knight
to d5
uh brings the knight into the game and
rook to e1 putting pressure on e6
so you have to be careful not to move
your queen away from the defense of this
pawn
and queen to c6 by nipple uh if
magnus is not careful something like
knight f4 attacking the queen the rook
and threatening checkmate
could could happen on the board so
magnus says there's no
there's no problem this is not a threat
yet he just goes to h4
for the moment the bishop guards the f4
square so it's not a problem
uh we have a5 nipple now starts
expanding on the queen side
uh and here magnus trades rook captures
on h8
rook captures and now even h5 nipple
continues
pushing on the queen side we have a4 and
now
bishop to d2 by magnus not a lot of
active possibilities for magnus as
like i said he he really needs a win to
get back into the match he does have the
white pieces
and so far nepo didn't give him any
chances he's playing very solid
and it's not uh not all that easy to
to make a breakthrough here so knight to
e7 by nepo
are shifting the knight over to f5 and
here magnus goes for something uh
that is very very interesting as
like i said you don't have a lot of
options here to create some chances in
the position but magnus finds one he
pushes
h6 he gives up this pawn temporarily
and allows nepal to capture it so you
cannot capture with the rook because the
bishop guards it but you can capture
with the pawn
uh this is what nepo does and magnus
immediately goes in with the queen
queen h5 check knight to g6 blocking
you could also go uh king to g7 to
defend the pawn but then you allow ideas
like rookie three rook g3 and even if
black
can defend against these threats uh
maybe it's a bit
bit too much to allow so here uh we have
knights to g6 instead nepo says okay
you're free to capture this pawn
but your bishop will not be able to move
for quite some time so bishop captures
now the bishop cannot move
and here comes queen to d6 by napo here
nipple missed a brilliant opportunity to
take the game straight into the end game
with queen d5
because now you have to trade queens you
have to play queen captures or go to an
incredibly passive square like queen to
h2 because
well if you play something like queen to
h3 then knight f4 just wins the game on
the spot because
you either lose uh lose the bishop the
queen is under attack and also there's
the threat of checkmate so you cannot
defend against all of these
threats so nepo's uh missed queen to d5
and magnus would have to trade queens
here and just go into
into an end game uh where nipple would
would have the upper hand
so he played queen to d6 instead but now
he just gives magnus a
few free moves rook to d1 attacking the
queen
queen to c6 uh and now also nipple
misses an opportunity to play rook
captures on h6 uh
immediately tray down into an end game
uh because here white's only good move
is
queen captures and g6 we would see a
recapture and then rook captures on d6
would go into a rook
and pawn end game with four pawns on
each side uh nepo
uh doesn't go for that either he goes a
queen to c6 instead
and now comes rook to d4 there's uh
always this possibility of queen
captures here followed by knight f4
check and picking up the queen but as
long as this knight is pinned
that's not happening so here rook d4
magnus grabs
hold of the fourth rank also ideas like
rook to g4 might be possible
so here f5 nepo prevents that but now
rook to d3 now the rook can go
uh well pretty much pretty much anywhere
and the queen has to be careful if you
lose control of d7 then
the rook is just incredibly strong here
so rook g8
uh and now bishop back to g5 we have
rook back to h8 by nippo challenging the
queen but magnus doesn't repeat magnus
goes back
queen to e2 and now comes queen to c7
threatening queen h to check followed by
queen to h1 checkmate and magnus needs
to do something about it
problem is if you weaken your king side
with the g3 then you get another
checkmate threat and then you have to
weaken your position further
not something magnus wants to do so
instead magnus makes the decision to
play rook h3 he decides to trade off a
pair of rooks and then play queen and
bishop against queen and knight
so rook captures g captures and now
queen to e5
nepal offers a queen trade and magnus of
course declines this queen back to d1
and now comes knight to f8 so it's a
it's an incredibly difficult position to
win for white
uh but uh magnus of course has to try
uh we have h4 he does have a pass pawn
so he might as well push it and now
king to g6 preventing any uh pushes of
the h pawn because then just
king captures bishop so queen to d8
uh threatening to to pick up the knight
here and now comes
uh queen to g7 a proper reply here
would have been uh king to f7 but it's
uh you know hard to follow everything
especially in a rapid game so here nepal
played queen to g7
but now the position is winning for
magnus unfortunately for nepo so feel
free to pause the video here and
win the game for magnus while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the
e8 square is not covered that's why we
said that queen to f7 was uh
king to f7 was much better uh so for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
queen to e8 check and this is what
magnus played
so he said all right i might not be able
to checkmate your king but i will gobble
up all of your pawns on the queen side
so king h7 and now queen capture sun b5
and now you have a problem
magnus will win this pawn and there's
there's not much you can do about it you
could play queen to d7 to try and defend
it like this and then maybe maybe try
and play descend game being upon down
but now magnus doesn't even have to
trade so he can just uh you know he he
has
two past pawns and he can even keep the
queens on the board
so here knight the g6 by nipple going
after this pawn
because you will not be able to capture
with the bishop but magnus just captures
an a4
now defends this pawn with the queen and
now he has
three can uh three pass pawns and it's
uh this is just overwhelming for nepo so
all of a sudden he was uh
holding magnus to a draw winning the
match and now uh he's going to have to
struggle to get a draw here
knights to e5 by nipple trying to get
this knight f3 check in but magnus
immediately stops at the queen f4
we have queen to h8 preparing to stop
those pawns on the queen side and magnus
of course starts pushing them b4 we have
king g6
and now queen to e3 the knight is
constantly threatened so
the queen has to be very careful where
she moves king of seven and now
b5 magnus just continues pushing his
past pawns queen to b8
as still defending this knight and now
of course
bishop f4 threatening to pick up the
knight and
the knight cannot move as the queen is
on b8 so queen g8
check only good move well relatively
good as there are no good moves in this
position
king to f1 and now knight to g4 attacks
the queen but
queen a7 check sorry queen a7 check
king to g6 and now queen to e7 going for
uh queen to g5
check uh if the queens get traded off
then it's just game over
white just pushes these pawns to victory
so nepo goes knight to f6
and now every movie is winning in this
position not every move obviously you
cannot play queen captures on f6 but
pretty much every good move is winning
so feel free to pause the video for the
last time and find the absolute best
winning move which ends the game
immediately
again while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on pushing that h
pawn and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show
yes it is h5 and uh it was in this
position almost 53 that yanni pony
should resign the game
and magnus equalized the match uh so
just to
show you what happens here if you
capture the pawn king captures on h5 and
you don't really have any other options
the bishop and queen cover all of the
squares
so you either capture with the king and
then you get queen captures on f6
now you're just down a piece completely
winning for white and if you capture
with the knight
not much better because queen g5 check
again picks up the knight king of seven
queen captures with
check and now it's a dead lost for black
so after this h5 move uh nipple resigned
and a great comeback in the match for
magnus carlsen and then uh
game three and game four also ended in a
draw and with magnus winning the first
match and drawing the second one it's
magnus cause and who
will go to the finals of the skilling
open and
in the other matchup in the matchup
hikaru vs wesley so wesley so won the
first match and
in the second match all four games ended
in a draw but they were
incredibly fighting games hikaru was uh
dead lost in uh pretty much all of them
i think
not not all of them but i'm pretty sure
he was dead lost in the first and the
second one but he was able to
miraculously pull off a draw
and i thought wow now now he's going to
win it but then wesley
i was able to to draw all the other
games and uh
it's wesley who who wins that match so
we will have magnus carlsen
versus wesley so in the finals of the
scaling open which means
uh clash of two world champions is
magnus is the reigning
world champion in every time format uh
whereas wesley is the world champion
unofficial world champion in
or was it the first official world i
think it was the first official official
random
uh well either way uh wasn't always the
world champion in the chess 960 or the
official random world world
chess champion so it's going to be it's
going to be wild
so yeah that's uh the game and the
coverage so far
i hope you guys are enjoying it i would
like to thank jason barr
bike communications llc dr marmotta
divya
andrew creel for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing with the finals of this
killing open checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your sunday